how are you guys doing Aaron Sampson
here and Ryan Schubert we were gonna
originally have a patch no conversation
regarding called G blackout them getting
rid of the 9 bang which you know you're
just blinding yourself out the time with
anyway that had to go where we landed
and said was actually that blackouts
kind of falling behind other Battle
Royale games and that has to do with a
couple different things called uni
players are kind of frustrated with the
season past in the microtransaction
system also just looking at what they
did with their blight father mini event
versus ORD nightmares which a larger
better more well executed event so let's
get into it let's talk about why
blackout is falling behind and I'm
talking about gameplay mechanics not
necessarily player population and I
think it's important to note that
blackout is really good it's a
foundation that needs a better building
on top of it so Call of Duty's parent
company Activision went on the record
last week during their earnings report
as putting pressure on destiny to to
basically make more money and I feel
like you can tie this all directly into
sort of what's wrong with blackouts
current progression system which is
based on fortnight season but it's just
not done nearly as well you basically
can't earn nearly enough playing regular
multiplayer much less blackout I think
that's the the root of the problem like
I primarily play multiplayer and the
unlocked regularity of the black market
stuff is actually pretty decent every so
many matches you're gonna unlock
something I'm not gonna say that I'm
overwhelmed or very excited about any of
the rewards I think that's something
they need to work on the which you get
isn't very interesting to me not to go
too deep into that just as a reflection
on it though Call of Duty World War 2
the previous game was bananas with skins
outfits variations on weapons like they
weren't just cosmetic changes they had
different impacts on X how XP was earned
depending on what weapons you had equip
there was a qualitative reason to earn
those things and there were some weapons
that were
actually event unique to start there
isn't really any of that in black ops 4
and that is just compounded by the fact
that if you're playing black out the
reward system is based almost entirely
on kills with a little bit of extra
bonus if you make it to the top 10
doesn't it feel like that just
completely misses the point of Battle
Royale the entire point of Battle Royale
isn't to kill it's basically to make the
last kill when you really boil it down
to it it's to make the last kill of the
match and not properly rewarding people
for that goal it seems like a huge
misstep you know if you played pub G as
an example you get rewarded for survival
for lasting longer I mean you get
bonuses for the kills you don't have to
make the top ten to come out of it with
a certain amount of points towards you
know your next loot crate or whatever
there's another problem now
so character customization so a big draw
of a game like fortnight is you earn
things and and you can equip those
things and over the weekend I decided to
finally go equip the skins that I'd
earned through a couple of events and I
had to look up a YouTube video on how to
do it because the button presses weren't
even obvious any game worth its salt
that's trying to engage in this kind of
a microtransaction system or season pass
your character has to be visible I'm
gonna just say within one button press
of the main screen so like for Knight
it's easy destiny you can pull up your
character anytime you want at all times
and and tweak it or look at it call it
duty with several button presses that
one of them was a button prompt that
isn't even on the on the menu like you
you don't know you have to hit option on
PlayStation no that's that's not the
worst one I've seen this week the worst
one this week definitely still goes to
battlefield 5 we counted no less than 6
button presses and that's got to be sort
of the low point of customization menus
you black out specifically but I also
worry about there is it feels very empty
and it's a pain to navigate you know
that's something I think it would be
wise to invest some effort into making
simpler making more accessible and
making the benefits and the rewards more
obvious
like in fortnight or pub G it's always
been apparent what is sort of possible
the character customization menus are
easy to get to it's easy to see what can
change what you're sort of looking for
and how to get it isn't hard to figure
out either
so this patch in blackout brought the
blight father zombie to the asylum area
the cemeteries particularly first of all
I think it's like the only special event
that they've had even though they had a
ton of special events in the beta like
close quarters fast clothes things like
that
fighting the blight father is such a
worse experience than safe the fort
nightmares experience that also just
happened in fort night we're zombies
spawned all over the map of their cube
monsters and when you fought the cube
monsters they would give you health
backs so when you got caught off guard
by other players they would give you
health and shield well I think Mosley
shields but if you got caught off guard
by another player you weren't at a huge
disadvantage for focusing on the fun
which was shooting the zombies and then
those armies would drop progressively
better and better loot over time you
know again going back to the idea of a
special event
that's how you do a special event like
fortnight had the Kevins story it had an
event start it had a story through the
season it had a one time event close and
it just did the cube monster so much
better than just the weird blight father
thing that happens on one place in the
map at one time where are the special
modes in Call of Duty I mean these are
the guys that excel at this stuff
I think the blight father aspect
specifically was underwhelming hey not
honestly that fun yeah and then B what
is the value of a reward if you get
killed trying to get it I felt like I
was more interested in looking for
opponents that were trying to do the
same thing then I wasn't actually
dealing with the blade father
the blight father showing up in the
final circle of a college a match would
be funny and kind of frantic and the
cube monsters were in the final circles
of fort nightmares which was funny and
frantic because you could tell when
another team had accidentally stumbled
across cube monsters in the last circle
because you would just see a giant troop
of cube bouncers pointing at a player
like frantically running away and you're
like oh I got this and then usually
while you were running after them you
would accidentally then trigger them
yourselves it was fun and it was funny
and and it was fair and it just feels
like the blight father was just kind of
shoved into one part of the map
without a lot of thought put into it on
some levels I want to give a little bit
of leeway to Call of Duty for being the
newcomer I know that it's a giant
triple-a game they've had plenty of time
to be prepared for this and it appears
as if they weren't but if anybody can
catch up with the pace set by epoch it
has to be Activision right so let's say
they do what you're saying and they get
it together they come up with some fun
creative modes which they have a history
of doing and they start rewarding you
properly for black out which I would
really appreciate so yeah if black out
wants to catch up to competitors and
again to be fair it's probably more of a
pubsey competitor than a fortnight at
this point I don't know in your mind
whoa what is black out need to do now
moving forward there's tons of room for
more unique things to be a part of black
out and that could that could be
anywhere from special modes to like
fortnight having the map fundamentally
change you know I would I like about at
least what I think they signaled with
the initial release of black out is a
willingness to pay homage to older Call
of Duty games and that means the sort of
sky is the limit as far as augmented
that map is concerned
yeah Majan if the zombie guys came in
and started putting secrets on the black
out map how interesting with that be
that would be super cool for me I'm a
little bit more interested in seeing
some of my old favorite maps reappear
and have opportunities to basically play
on them again there's a few maps that
are already in black out that the second
I find myself in them I just have
flashbacks to the like hundreds of hours
of multiplayer I played on them speaking
of nuke down is actually coming in this
week that's gonna be a miss all right so
those are our thoughts on blackout and
why it's kind of falling behind is a
battle royale game it's still pretty
dang good though just for the record as
a pretty dang good battle royale game
yes it's definitely a well I know it's
in the top three of the three battle
royale games that people are playing
regardless of course but I think the
court the core is there
it needs more and we want to know what
you guys think what kind of special
events do you want to see come to
blackout particularly because again Call
of Duty has been really good at these
kinds of modes in the past also let us
know what other games you guys are
interested in if you're not playing
blackout battlefields out we're gonna be
looking at division 2 and anthem later
this year and maybe that's where your
your minds already gone or hell
firestorm which is not even gonna be
here till spring that's true I am
looking forward to see where World War 3
goes I want to see that game get more
interesting and honestly still playing
Red Dead Redemption yeah fair enough
alright thank you for watching everyone